COUTURE WITH THE SHOT AND THE
SAT NIETO WINS THAT
DRAW BACK AND H
DAHLEN CENTRES IT.
LON.
CENTRING PASS BY DAHLEN.
THAT'S
IN FOR COUTURE.
SHOT AND MURRAY MAKES THE STOP .
HERE'S LABANC BACK WITH IT.
PASS AHEAD FOR BONINO, KNOC OTT
1-NOTHING LEAD!
ROLLS HIS WRIST.
HE HAS NORRIS AT THE B
JONES.
MARTIN JONES SEEMS TO HAVE COMI
SAN JOSE ASACK
UP A LITTLE BIT.
HE HAS FOUR POINTS IN TWO GAMES
BY MATT MURRAY. THE  A BIG SHOT
CONNOR BROWN DROPS IT BACK.
NICK PAUL IN, SHOOTS, REIMER GOT
AN ARM ON THAT TO SHIFT.
EVERYTHING BUT FINDININUST
PUTS THIS UNDERNEATH THE BAR. LT
FROM THAT ANGLE.
COGLIANO.
>> Gord: HE'S O POSITIONING AND
DETERMINATION AND THEY'RE
CRUNCHED BY DEL ZOTTO.
TO TRY IT OUT.
TRIES TO BAT I B GOAL FOR SAN JO
THE OTTAW
BODY NOT LETTING HIM PUNCH BONI
AND HANGS ON.
>> Jamie: STRONG PLAY BYAY.
WILLIAM EKLUND.
BACK TO K KARLSSON, LOOKING
FOR THE HOLE.
THE BACK SIDE OF JOSH BROWN,3-N
THIRD PERIOD, SCORES FOUR
STRAIGHT TPASS, POKED OUT BY  MT
THE START OF THE SEASON LAST
YEAR, NEW ORGANIZATION, C C
BRIEFLY FOR THE SECOND BUT GOT
BRADY TKACHUK ALL AROUND IT AND
NORRIS HITS THE CROSS BAR.
>> Gord: REIMER GLO
MICHAEL DEL ZOTTO...DERSON THE
THE FOOT OF CHABOT AND THAT